hey guys uh welcome back to the channel
hope you're all having a nice day uh I
just want to say thank you all for
40,000 subscribers uh not only doesn't
mean a lot to me uh but you know I
really don't care too much about the
subscriber number The View number uh the
ad Revenue number or anything like that
really what matters to me the most is
just seeing how these videos impact you
guys uh pretty much my metric of success
or anything like that is just how many
people reach out to me letting me know
that they got their dream offer in part
due to this Channel and that's really
what does it for me at the end of the
day so um thank you a lot for all the
support um I'm probably not going to go
and make a slideshow of all those uh
those offers just yet I'll do it in a
little bit batch them up uh but yeah I
really appreciate it have a great day
let's go ahead and do some systems
design okay so today should hopefully be
a fairly fun video uh in which we'll be
talking about a distributed priority
queue now this one is absolutely killing
me uh because I heavily based it off
some Facebook paper that they released a
couple years ago called fqs or Fox I
don't know how they want to pronounce it
but uh the gist is you know I was
racking my brain for like many many
hours even days on how to build this
thing came up with what I thought was a
pretty good solution probably over
complicated it read their paper and I
was just like h i could have just been
doing this the whole time that was so
much easier and then I still tried to
improve upon it couldn't do it realized
that the Improvement that I thought I
made on their design was actually in
their paper and then I felt like an
idiot so I've been humbled by about 10
separate engineers at Facebook but uh
maybe I'll get them another day so let's
go and talk about what they more or less
did so a company like Facebook or Google
or any massive one like that does need
something like a distributed priority
queue the reason being that they have
tons of jobs that they want to run in an
automated fashion they want to run them
asynchronously and ideally certain jobs
are you know more important to run than
others so they want to be assigning them
with some sort of arbitrary priority so
let's say for example as you can see I
have in the drawing something like a
video encoder right maybe we've got uh
one video over here with Priority One
we've got the presidential debate over
here with priority 2 and we've got a
last video over here with priority 3
basically our distributed priority queue
is going to allow us to build out a
scalable and fault tolerance system with
fairly good read and write through putut
that's going to allow all of these
separate video encoders to basically
pick off all of these items and make
sure that they all get processed at
least once cool so I guess the gist is
you know the second that you go ahead
and hear uh from a node saying that uh
your video that you want to process is
in the system it should eventually get
processed cool let's go ahead and talk
about some problem requirements so
basically to formalize this out we want
to build an ordered list of items but of
course it's not enough to build an
ordered list of items right we've done
that with Kafka we've done that with
jmss Brokers like active mq or rabbit mq
we want to be able to assign them each a
priority cool so we have this concept of
priority on our ordered list and we want
to be able to support some operations in
queing modifying an existing item we
want to be able to DQ and probably we
want to be sure that if uh an item is
actually in one of these lists that it
is going to be delivered and processed
at least once typically the way that you
would make sure that you know results
only happen exactly once is you probably
have some sort of item potency key or
some sort of item potent function that's
going to be run as a result of handling
your message uh but I'm not really going
to talk about this too much here as
we've talked about it plenty in the past
so last aspect of this is that we want
our system to be both scalable and Fa
top an so I guess that's not really a
functional requirement but uh it is
something that is going to be required
even if we have billions of
messages cool so the first thing I want
to do is quickly give a moment to
ordered consumption because you may be
thinking oh you know like we want to
build this massive queue out right and
so when we're talking about just like a
normal Q or like a fifo q uh you know
you have active mq or jmss Brokers where
I guess the consumption of the messages
is unordered and then you also have
Kafka where basically as long as you
have one consumer uh per partition all
of the messages in that partition are
going to be consumed in an ordered
fashion so the gist is I guess the same
thing really applies here right can we
guarantee that all of our messages are
going to be processed in order yes but
only if our queue has one consumer at a
time if you have multiple consumers
inherently in order to take advantage of
the fact that you have multiple
consumers you want multiple messages to
be delivered to those consumers at once
and of course if that happens just due
to some sort of race condition one of
the later messages can be fully
processed before an earlier one so if
this is the earlier message and this is
the later message you can see that the
earlier one's delivered first the later
one is delivered second but ultimately
maybe the later one gets processed first
and gets put in some database sync over
here while the early one gets processed
second now this is going to be a
challenge that we inherently have to
deal with but my point is here we're not
going for perfect ordering within our
priority queue because at the end of the
day we probably want to have more than
one consumer if we only wanted one
consumer this would be a very different
problem and we could just go ahead and
build like a heap or something in
but uh yeah okay so keep in mind that
we're not going for ordered consumption
we're going for pretty much like an
approximate priority que and here's the
best way that we can try and do that so
there are a few different ways that we
can Implement a priority queue if I went
to you after you took your data
structures and algorithms class you
would probably say okay well let's do it
with a heap right and a heap is pretty
simple because it allows you um constant
time accesses of the top element of the
Heap so if you're looking for the number
with the lowest priority for example and
it's a Min Heap you can easily find that
and then of course uh when you pop it
you have to do some logarithmic actions
in order to rebalance the Heap so we
would Implement that as an array and the
question is is that something that is
easy to implement on dis well probably
not because there are a ton of random
shuffles that you have to do of the
array element right like keep would
basically be like this is the first
level right here these two guys are the
second
level you know this over here is going
to be the third level and so on and so
if you're switching elements between
this this spot or this spot all the time
now you're all of a sudden you're
jumping around that list it's probably
not going to be too great for uh a hard
drive so how could we do this on dis
only well actually we do have a fairly
good way of doing it which is using just
like a normal B tree or an LSM tree
based index the reason being that we can
actually maintain a sorted list and
because it's a sorted list we can really
easily access the first element that
being said something like an LSM tree or
a B tree based index is still going to
be fairly slow because at the end of the
day it is based on disk and in addition
to that uh it's basically just going to
be the fact that you know we'll need an
index eventually for some ID of every
single node uh meaning that we can't
perfectly uh denormalize the data we're
going to have to normalize the data and
so we're going to probably be jumping
around the disc a lot as a result of
that uh and so we're not going to you
know we're going to have a lot more
expensive rights as a result uh we have
all of these uh log n insertions into
our index and also if we delete an
element from the top of our sorted list
we may potentially have to Reb balance
our index if it's something like a b
tree so we can have a lot of expensive
operations going on in the background
there but also just in general memory is
a lot faster than dis so what could we
perhaps do instead well we may be able
to implement some sort of hybrid
approach so in this case we could
actually do the Heap itself in memory or
rather the sorted list itself but some
sort of data structure where we
basically have a sorted list of all the
primary keys of the nodes ordered by
their priority and in turn what we can
do is have pointers to the data on on
disk what this allows us to do basically
is just insert a bunch of data on disk
when we insert it which is going to be
an O of one right to the end of some
sort of log almost like Kafka then we
can basically you know simultaneously
have derived data in memory which is
basically going to be that uh sorted
index of all of those node IDs but I'll
explain that in a little bit so to just
make sure that this is some uh feasible
for the type of scale that we're looking
for well if every single node needs some
sort of priority and it also needs a
pointer to the actual data location on
disk imagine that's 8 Bits for the
priority 8 Bits for the pointer that's
16 bits overall and so as a result of
that uh if we have a billion nodes
that's 16 gabt on disk so not too bad
actually we can totally store that or
sorry 16 gigabytes in memory and again
that is fairly reasonable for a modern
day server especially if we start to
partition this thing out cool and again
we can do this regardless of how big the
nodes are because our limiting factor is
probably going to be memory and all we
really need to store in memory is just
this one thing right here so what does
this actually look like to really try
and solidify that in everyone's
understanding well it would be some sort
of hybrid priority cue right where in
memory over here we have a
heap or a sorted list whatever you
prefer to do and then over here on the
right on disk we basically have
something that almost resembles just
like a right Ahad log where as nodes
come in they get assigned some sort of
ID based on their location so that
should be super easy to do we just order
everything everything popping into the
dis then in addition to the ID we have
the actual data in reality this is
probably going to be pretty big because
it could be something like a video frame
or a small video chunk or something like
that or anything else that we might want
to process asynchronously in the
background and then finally of course we
have our priority so regardless of how
these things are ordered on disk when we
actually go to memory we order them
properly and so again the dis rights are
going to be o of1 of course in memory uh
it's probably going to be o of log n
where there are N Things in the Heap
because we have to insert it in the
proper place of the
Heap cool now let's go ahead and talk
about modifying some inced elements so
keep in mind that one of the things that
we wanted to be able to do was basically
take an existing element that's on disk
somewhere like down here and be able to
actually change the data or perhaps even
change the priority well if we do that
fortunately like I mentioned we're
assigning an ID to every single uh
element of our Heap as it's going in and
so we can actually use that ID the fact
that this is already going to be sorted
by
ID just like an index and then really
really quickly uh figure out where that
lives on disk so that is going to make
life easier for us the one expensive
thing to do would be if we actually
changed the uh priority of the node
itself because then we would have to go
over here do some sort of inmemory
update and that's not exactly the
easiest thing to do perhaps then instead
of doing a heap we might want to do some
sort of sorted link list with a hashmap
where where the hashmap is basically
going from node ID to a particular
element of the list or something like
that so that we could access it in
constant
time cool hopefully that's starting to
make sense but the gist is we want all
these operations to be Atomic I think it
would be really really nice if we could
just keep everything simple use
something like a standard SQL database
uh and yeah that should hopefully make
our life a little bit
easier of course though if you are
aiming for uh you know faster reads or
writes then you know maybe you'll choose
a different database if you're able to
fit everything in memory that could be
great but yeah I mean we pretty much
have a right ahead log right here and
then we also have a separate inmemory
index so you're basically looking for a
database that implements a sorted
inmemory index for you otherwise you
would effectively just build something
out like this on your
own cool let's talk about replication
quickly to get a better sense of what's
going on here so we want to be sure that
basically all of our messages are going
to be delivered so what options do we
have well for starters we have
multi-leader replication which basically
means that if we want to write to the
same node ID from multiple different
regions that we could that being said I
don't really know that this is going to
be a huge requirement of our system the
reason being I can't imagine that people
from multiple different regions are
going to be modifying the same task to
be processed asynchronously it could
happen but it seems like at least for
this case it's probably less likely and
so we're not going to get that much
benefit there and it also comes at the
cost of potentially having to deal with
right conflicts when that that does
occasionally happen in theory we could
do leaderless replication if we wanted
some sort of strong consistency right so
we could try and use Quorum consistency
in order to effectively ensure that you
know within a partition of our priority
queue or something that uh we make sure
that every single event that goes in
there is replicated sufficiently such
that it doesn't get lost so that's
actually not a terrible idea and could
potentially avoid us you know having to
do something like a two-phase commit to
make sure that all events are
synchronously rep replicated somewhere
uh but at the end of the day I think
that uh you know if we just kind of go
towards single leader replication we may
end up getting faster read and write
response time so it seems pretty
preferred to me finally we could do
single leader replication however again
single leader replication is not perfect
in the sense that uh you know if you
write to a single leader and then you're
doing asynchronous replication and the
single leader goes down before that
message gets asynchronously replicated
all of a sudden that message is lost so
what we could is uh something we've
started to talk about a little bit more
which is use a consensus algorithm with
some sort of like replication group
where you know let's say every single
leader has two followers that message
has to be synchronously replicated to
one of the followers uh before you know
we can proceed right because uh that's
kind of how something like raft works
you have to get a majority of nodes to
agree that the message is real before
you can proceed and uh consider it a
successful right so we can do that and
the nice thing about that is that you
know when we do see that a certain note
exists uh we can just read it from the
leader and then we only have to read the
message from one place so that actually
helps us with our read speeds compared
to something like Quorum
consistency cool let's go ahead and talk
about partitioning so we want to
basically make our read and our write
throughput as fast as humanly possible
because we want this thing to be a
massive system at scale so what does
that really mean well it means we want
to decrease our read and write load from
a single node in any of our partitions
so another thing to note is we're
already handling message events out of
order right I mentioned that we're
likely going to have multiple consumers
here as opposed to just one and because
we have multiple consumers anyway uh it
basically means that we're never going
to get perfect ordering and so actually
using something like round robin will
probably be the most Fair way to
distribute events by their priorities uh
or rather not by their priorities but
just completely randomly and that way we
can ensure that you know you have
consumers reading from every sing Le
node and as long as they're doing that
even if we're not getting perfect
priority ordering across all nodes we're
still doing this pretty well another op
option as opposed to round robin would
actually be to like
Partition by
priority or like by the range of
priority but the problem with that is
assuming priority is like a continuous
value and there's not just like uh you
know you can have one two and three
priority assuming we can literally have
any number as our priority then what
that could lead to is a lot of uh hot
reads on the top Shard because at the
end of the day when you're doing a
priority queue all of the reads are
going to be coming from one note so even
though the rights may be spread out
first of all there could be an uneven
distribution in the priority ranges
provided but also the reads are going to
be completely locked in on that one node
and because we're not getting fairly
ordered rights anyway because we have a
bunch of consumers consuming from that
one node it doesn't really benefit us to
be only consuming from one place so I
thought a lot about this concept of like
trying to Partition by priority when I
was thinking through this video but
ultimately doing this thing round robin
and basically just randomly spreading
out events is probably going to be the
best way to get this
done cool so now we know that we have
events going to many partitions right so
this could be like partition
one and we' you know we've got our
little like Heap in
memory and data on
disk this could be partition two this
could be partition three it is possible
that we might have one particular
consumer that is actually reading from
multiple partitions at once so if this
were to be the case how would we go
ahead and do it well actually we would
probably want to make sure that we're
aggregating the data across all three of
these nodes at once and then picking the
one with the highest priority across all
three of them so the way that we could
do that is basically by having a
consumer over here establishing its own
little Heap in memory and basically
picking from the top of the Heap so this
could be the one from partition one one
and then it'll have to reach out to
partition one again to basically back
fill this Heap once this guy is
processed so the way that we can do that
at least in my opinion is probably going
to be best done with something like a
long pole the reason being that using a
websocket here or a server sent event
especially if uh our cues are or sorry
especially if our priority queue is not
especially busy it basically means that
uh we're going to be maintaining a
persistent connection when probably most
of the time we don't need to maintain
that persistent connection if these
events actually take fairly long time to
process then you know this guy's going
to have a lot of downtime where it
doesn't actually need to ask for another
event and so just fetching one event as
opposed to maintaining a persistent
connection the whole time seems like a
much better solution here I also wrote
downtown instead of downtime because my
brain doesn't work that's a shame cool
finally let us go ahead and go into our
actual design so again we've got our
client on the left this guy is someone
who is going to be publishing to our
priority
when we do that the first thing that we
do is hit our load balancer which is
going to use round robin the reason
being is that we can't ensure a perfect
ordering of all of our events by their
priorities as long as we have multiple
consumers anyway so we may as well
approximately spread them out and just
have our consumers listen to certain
priority notes that's going to make our
life a lot easier then over here
basically the kind of priority CU itself
will be held on a mySQL database so
effectively we're just inserting in
primary key order like right into a log
ideally o of one inserts onto disk and
then separately maintaining this derived
data structure of a heap over on memory
so in memory we're basically going to be
indexing on the priority score and then
of course within our partition like I
mentioned we're going to be doing some
replication with paxos or raft or any
other consensus algorithm the reason for
that being that once we've actually
properly done that uh paxos or raft
algorithm we can be sure that the
message is going to be fault tolerant
and will eventually be read that is an
extremely important part of this so what
does that look like in real life well it
basically means you propose to one node
you propose to another node this is the
proposed
phase they both come back and say
whether or not they'll do it it almost
looks like a two-phase commit except the
difference here is that you only need a
majority approval so if this guy doesn't
actually ever respond because he's down
we only are able to send the message to
the other node right over here but since
we got a majority of approval and that
node goes through we can actually go
back to the client and say Hey you wrote
successfully your thing is in our system
it's going to get processed now of
course from there we have our consumers
so it's possible that you could say have
one consumer sharing a single partition
with another consumer and if that were
to happen you would basically use
locking over here to Ure that they're
both not receiving the same event and
then of course once they acknowledge
that event that they've handled it
properly that event is then deleted or
marked as deleted from uh the MySQL
table cool additionally if you have a
consumer over here that is handling
multiple partitions then we have to do
what I described before which is
basically do long
polls to the nodes that they care
about aggregate some sort of local list
where you get the priorities of each
node and figure out which one's the next
one that you want to handle and then
handle them accordingly writing back to
the database and saying hey I just
handled your last event please give me
your next one of highest priority so I
can consider that well guys hopefully
you found this fairly useful again this
is not really my design I kind of just
stole it from Facebook which is a nice
feeling uh but it is a fairly good
design and I see why they use it and I
see how it does scale so Props to them
for that one anyways hope all of you
have a great day thanks again for uh the
channel landmark and enjoy your weekend